oddio ciao ciao a tutti ben 26 giusto ed
oggi andremo a vedere dei trucchetti
assurdi tra nissim i divertenti se
ridere o piangere
mettetevi comodi patatine bocca naso più
belle life e iniziamo subito allora
altro che per uno se non hai delle
scarpe notizie plastica e geniale questa
cosa geniale proprio massimo trucchetto
si è visto che non c'è un porta bevante
caldo da auto luca oggi c'è ma quanto
reggerà questo la prima a bordo fino ad
ora teca 19 il cappuccino aveva subito
ad ora no vabbè terribile nascondere il
cibo dal dai professori o mio dio
che schifo grafica apre però anche
vittima fair means carte non capisco
l'utilità che tutta la città distribuite
nel telefono attaccato metti un elastico
attorno certo avrei troppa paura che
micale mauri con l'arma così non cade
oggi perché però scritti cateno
l'elastico la cuffia
così non lo so anche pessimo trucchetto
se non trovi un segnalibro sporche libro
di ketchup così sicuramente ritroverai
il segno per questo certo del male non
capiti è una scoperta si stanno
scaldando salsiccia non soluzione noi un
riff e cipolle fritte di avere di
cipolla ma studia la forchetta infilata
nel perfetto ma non è dentro quella è la
protezione e quasi quasi a rischio corto
circuito si aiuta
che brutto
in pratica seriamente le testine del
rasoio che si possono sostituire ma non
avete la madre inoltrata con forchette
allora grattugiamo in formaggio nella
parete dinko kit bagno pulito non è fa
la polvere bellissimo ho fatto un porta
è un portatele fono tipo del suono
se questo quindi amplifica il suono ha
fatto un drink nel carrello genio dei
magneti per continuo che soffia sulla
per terra fob usa dei magneti al frigo
per tenere
la busta di pattumiera attaccata diciamo
che la portò via del signore scrivo a
voi ingrandire lo schermo del telefono
passa che lo metti in un bicchiere
d'acqua con dell'acqua dentro andrebbero
completamente ma meglio non farlo
lord no vabbè dicesse city fretta la
mattina e non hai tempo per fare
colazione davanti 20 metti il
dentifricio del top così si sa che
mantenere la croazia che ti ne avrà i
denti a aprirti precedenti può mangiare
non va bene mangiarlo un consiglio se
dovete andare in bagno e dice dovete
fare è attendere un bagno fare i
bisognini ferito prissimo un implenia
sports ad ora immaginate come quasi in
bagno allora se ti senti solo prendi un
guanto riempito di acqua calda e
metterlo sulla martedì sembra che
qualcuno si sta aprendo
selphy attraverso patologico terze
genica così sembra che tu sei la luna
questo lo dobbiamo fermare se vuole fare
una foto un minuto solamente brava di
teatro ha puntato i tetti si rompe il
faro della macchina 3 infine attacca
carote come anno rimanere attaccate con
lo scotch rimasto fatto segnare solo
stare attenti a non cadere creare e tor
cinema in casa basta mente in una prima
ma dietro però alzato da delle serie
così che sta dietro questi ad amanti del
fai da te da e questo potrebbe
funzionare non aspetta c'è anche scritto
che lo sta vendendo per 25 dollari
però chissà se visite a venderlo senza
da righe accostamenti oppure atea o vuoi
creare questo fatto in casa di fili oggi
sembra titolo tipo un palo elettrico
se hai bisogno di una certa di
compleanno una tesi fretta semplicemente
presunto amante metti dell'accendino a
tre però tenendo premuto con un nastro
isolante mantenersi chetrit questo il
segnale se vuoi che il tuo ipad tuo
tablet diventi una tv aperta la
attestava al filo pettinatore club
grazie
non so se qualcuno per sbaglio fa
partire il ventilatore che non c'è più
acqua calda immagino scali l'acqua con
una candela attaccata al tubo si chiama
funziona da una laurea c'è scritto se
non ebbe successo di per comprare un po
da cucina un robot da cucina paolo
frullato per cambiare le cose
attacca un coltello a un ventilatore non
l'ho fatto
e poi c'è questo è uno strumento di
tortura
addio
[Musica]
martelli inglese mangiano luogo solo
colazione ma si va non solo gli inglesi
penso mi ricordo quando da ufficio c'era
una mia collega che mancava a sentirlo
godo alle 7 del mattino e riempiva tizio
di una puglia terrificante e da quel
giorno non molto più comunque dice se
non è in tempo la mattina per preparare
la prossima
metti luogo dentro un crudo quindi
dentro il caffè caldo così nel frattempo
si cucina e neanche un uovo sodo e nel
frattempo il programma vi attaccate le
torce nel lampadario bel fine funziona
conti ha fatto c è paura noi che abbiamo
visto un paese con con le prese
differenti conosciamo bene questo tipi
di problemi ma non così il freddo è
troppo fredda questo tappeto non sembra
neanche molto morbido
[Musica]
un altro porta bevande macchina scarpa
questa scarpa tra l'altro nuovissima
pulitissima magari se l'atto era tolta
la mattina e pure cauto ma per scaldare
l'acqua ferro da stiro sulla pentola
sotto ottima si fermava soprattutto
dallo spirito che sta in uno scarpone
mantiene con un tema torino livello
l'ordinaria click per le tende proviamo
ormai infatti tutti diventati tornare
per la lattina l'addio a che si sia la
tos che chiedono la macchina metti un cd
mi sembrava tutto identico addio no
vabbè quante persone in vesti così no
questo per mangiare in macchina quando
si pensi che se non è una doccia ha
perduto abito canio ma tastiera trattati
con questa persona dice non ho bisogno
delle formine per il disco la bomba sia
reso diventati dei cerchi per chi vuole
fornire questa è una jeans kate che
hanno cercato di replicare doveva uscire
così ma non è più buono seascape e poi
guardate quel successo qua è esplosa
pratica
che cos'ha combinato nello stesso sangue
la bocca
allora la figlia doveva farla così
sorridente crescendo un mostro deforme
va beh oddio perderà questa anzi scritto
mio padre cercato di cucinare fatto per
tappe del compleanno di mia mamma almeno
ci ha provato ma l'ha fatta sui fornelli
arriva da fuori dal forno ma c'è una
cosa né col ora che mi dice che forse un
po troppo cotto sembra un vulcano allora
questa torta bellissima dei muppets dio
sono campo di fare di con gli abbracci
ei visto tv di colore di due colori
chiamava famiglia e invece introdotto si
sono sciolti completamente voleva fare
il tipo le tombe per hanno un biscotto
con la tomba idraulico
oddio adesso fa all'hotel aspettativa
civile per questa è l'area ma perchè
l'ha fatto con cioccolato bene ideale
trasformare i contadini in mini
zucchette so che questi su canini lo
stesso secondo me volevo fare delle
varie altre tizio aveva torturato quando
strutturato scheletro che è un htc
diventato moglie a tutti che carini
[Musica]
l'obiettivo
ok adesso pare quello il mio posso
ridere di più di questi trucchetti a
storie di rai pazzo ei c'è anche voi
avete fatto dei files così mandatecele
così possiamo vederli tutti insieme alla
spagna rita story scorso
se volete altri ragazzi se volete vedere
altri video del genere nel si dimette
montato a poli quindi fateci sapere nei
commenti che altri video vorreste vedere
e noi vi lasciamo ora fruttate linee
super cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video challenge pt assurdi cliccate qui
su quella che preferite e buona visione
ciao